[Music]
November 2014 the worldview 3 satellite
is passing over the vast empty
wilderness of Australia's Northwest Cape
when it captures a huge symbol edged
onto the earth the strangest thing about
this image is its geometric regularity
these lines are very straight the
markings are very clear the shape covers
over one and a half square miles
hexagons a mile wide in the middle of
the desert the site is one of the
furthest points west on the Australian
continent it's miles from anything close
analysis of the image reveals that at
the points of the hexagram there are
thin spike like structures casting long
shadows zooming in on this image we see
a massive array of antennae so the
original pattern we saw was actually
roads connecting all these antennae for
servicing this is no mine the worldview
3 satellite has captured an aerial image
of the most secretive and controversial
military site in Australia a site
established by the US military
it's called base Harold Holt and it's a
u.s. Navy Australian Navy collaboration
they use it to communicate with ships
all over the world
the bass is rumored to operate
top-secret space surveillance systems
developed at White Sands Missile Range
people believe that these hexagon
antennae transmit very low frequency
radio waves these are used among other
things to issue orders to submerged
nuclear submarines extreme low-frequency
e.l.f penetrates into the water because
it's got a long wavelength it's hard to
communicate the submarines
really
and that's an important thing to be able
to talk to your nuclear guys some people
believe that signals from the hexagon
interfered with the controls of a
civilian plane in 2008 forcing it to
make an emergency landing and injuring
over 70 people the incident provoked
speculation that the site could be part
of a secret radio wave weapons program
the International Pilots Association has
called for commercial aircraft to be
barred from the area as a precaution
[Music]
access to the Harold E Holt facility is
highly restricted even today the secrets
of what goes on here remain classified